there you go all right let's get to your
top five takeaways how we start the show
every week here rod your first takeaway
that you have is marquis hollywood brown
a guy we've been critical of in the past
had some drops we obviously know we
spent some time with them on the field
after the kansas city game which was a
great game comes back around where does
he stand right now hollywood brown
man man just showing some mental
toughness he had three drops last week
and then this sunday he came through had
a huge just a beautiful catch in the end
zone just a nice pass it was uh i don't
know 50 60 yards down the field it was a
beautiful pass by lamar thank you it was
a beautiful pass by lamar but
just think about the mental toughness as
a young player dropping three last week
and then being able to come back and
make it one of the most incredible
catches i've seen all year this should
do a lot to his confidence and just look
at the speed justin simmons is all pro
safety and he just runs right past him
great concentration he hauls it in great
job marquis brown keep bouncing back
brother
hey i want to ask you one other question
when it comes to them and i'm right
there with you on hollywood brown we
knew that he would that could be a
mental position we have some bad drops
in the game that he did a week ago it's
it's you know that a couple more could
follow it and that's what happened to
him he's a great wide receiver getting
back to that his trust in his
relationship with lamar jackson i just
think that duo is going to continue to
grow every single season there was
another issue that came up at the end of
that game though this ravens rushing
situation they have where they keep
going over 100 yards this long streak
they put together vic fangio did not
like the last play of the game and was
more than vocal about it whose side were
you on with that there at the end like
where is the line between the
gamesmanship and everything we saw
between harbaugh and fangio
the way i was taught and coach belichick
re-emphasiz like re-emphasize it when i
came to new england is you play every
play like it's your last play you got to
play 60 minutes sometimes you got to
play a little longer so if somebody
decides to come out and run a play a
trick play or something like that you
always have to be ready for it i think
vic fangio was out of line he has to
teach his team to be able to finish
games period
i i am right there with you on that one
okay your second headline aj dylan we've
we've talked a lot rodney about this
packers backfield between aaron jones
and aj dillon see i i right now i'm very
curious to know which direction you're
going to go positive or negative all i
got in my rundown is two words aj dylan
which direction are you going with him
aj dylan we cussed him out last week we
talked about they wasted a second round
draft choice i don't know if matt
lafleur heard us or not but aj dillon
was actually solid i went back and
watched the tape he had 15 carries for
81 yards the guy ran with purpose he ran
hard he ran in between the tackles and
he was a bruising force i thought he did
a really good job
so i actually am going to disagree with
you and this will be the first
disagreement of the show this week feels
good i went back re-watched all of them
just because his name was in the rundown
and i think he was the exact same guy
the exact same
you know what i think was different the
packers offensive line if you go watch
some of his runs from dylan he's seven
eight yards down the field before he's
getting touched by the time he does get
touched he's going down i'm thinking
about the long run he broke down to
about the one yard line he didn't get
touched so he was 20 yards down the
field and then the first guy who meets
him is a db and he brings him down right
before the goal line i thought jones was
awesome i thought dylan was better but
the reasons he was better was because
the offensive line not because he's some
new human being in week four or week
five no
right of course not and i'm not saying
that but what i'm saying is for a guy
that's a second round draft choice and
you know that you need this guy
you want him to have positive games like
this so he can continue to build his
confidence remember he has aaron jones
in front of him a guy that signed a
four-year 48 million dollar contract and
he's coming in in spot duty last year he
came in really didn't get a lot of gold
but this year matt lafleur is starting
to show more confidence in his guys so
when you can go out and get 15 carriers
for 81 yards and make some positive runs
get out in the open field and see what
it feels like to be out in space by
yourself then you know you can start to
feel good about yourself but
as a pro you have to be able to do it
consistently week in and week out we'll
see what happens here in the future
with the packers i worry about them
losing jair alexander who had the
shoulder injuries that fourth and one
where he comes up to phil makes a big it
makes a great play but immediately he's
the best player on defense and that
shoulders
the best player on defense one of the
best corners in the league first round
pick louisville but you could just tell
something was up with him right away and
that shoulder is kind of lingering on
the ground it was a bad weekend for dbs
rod and now if the packers lose
alexander where does that put him on the
defensive side of the ball
oh it's going to put him in a tough
situation because you have eric stokes
out there and you have kevin king who
was inside well he was outside and he
moved him inside so it's just a bunch of
confusion i mean just like tampa bay you
might have to sign some guys off the
practice squad might have to go into
free agency guys sitting at home and see
who you can sign but you definitely need
depth at the defensive back position
yeah well they're gonna have to look
beyond richard sherman he's already
playing for tom brady in the tampa bay
buccaneers all right let's get to your
third takeaway the cowboys coaches they
seem to have it cooking from where i'm
sitting what's the big takeaway when it
comes to the cowboys coaching staff
i'm looking at the assistant coaches and
i just think that um dan quinn has he's
come in he's done a wonderful job just
changing the mindset and also dan quinn
he's evolved as a defensive coordinator
it's no longer just the cover three
system that he had in seattle he's doing
different things and his ability to take
a rookie linebacker and be able to move
him all over the place play middle
linebacker play left in right in it just
shows how he's evolved as a defensive
coordinator i think those safeties are
playing tremendous
digs he right now to me he's the
defensive player of the year if he
continues we talked about him so i like
what they're doing on the defensive side
of the ball but i also have to give a
lot of credit
to kellen moore i think he's done a
wonderful job of having dak prescott
spread the ball around zeke it looks
like he's running with a sense of
urgency you see um tony pollard he's
running they're doing a wonderful job
kellen moore is doing a wonderful job of
just spreading the ball around from a
defensive standpoint it's hard to defend
that because dak is such a great leader
such a great decision maker and he's
giving he's getting everybody involved
you mentioned so many great points right
there the one that i just want to follow
up on and hit hard is that i think it's
all comes down to this team having their
identity back having the star back and
what i think that is is this offensive
line and when these guys are moving
mountains when you go back and watch
that game they are moving mountains and
the way that they used to a few years
ago like i watched zach martin get his
guy help the next level and get to a
third guy on multiple plays i'm like
this this guy plays offensive guard
better than anybody i've seen and it may
just be my generation but he is better
than anybody in my generation and this
oftentimes i want to give love to
everybody tyron smith connor williams
has been great zach martin has been
phenomenal terence steele at the right
tackle position has been great i think
this offensive line is back to their
best form and with that with that being
said and zeke and the games he's able to
produce and back back and playing with
these weapons this cowboy team's real
man i really think they're real
yeah no doubt man and i mentioned zack
martin last week and and watching him on
tape it's
if if fans don't literally watch him on
tape you don't realize like how great he
is like to me he's a hall of famer right
now that's how good he is and i saw the
exact same thing he'll come help on the
double team go get the linebacker chip
the corner i mean he's doing a multitude
of things i just absolutely love it what
zack martin is doing
and then then he'll run down the field
20 yards and try to block somebody man
it's just amazing you talk about this
offensive line i'm just really really
really pumped up about this offensive
line and you see a new zeke you see a
zeke with energia zeke that's getting up
feeding himself talking trash just
playing with a lot of energy and if the
cowboys can keep these guys healthy the
offensive line
man and give that time with his decision
making you're right the cowboys will be
a real problem
and the defense will continue to improve
that's big and you hit those defensive
points and i know that dax saying that
he is not going to run like he used to
that's kind of the narrative and i do
think he needs to be more careful when
he runs but the reality is he's still
gonna run i mean did you watch that game
yesterday some really big runs he broke
off with his legs i'm thinking about the
one where he drops the snap back there
and takes off and runs for 20 yards
there's one in the third quarter where
he ran for about 25 yards down the left
sideline does he look quite as explosive
maybe not to the same level but i think
he's also still easing his way back into
it but that running it may be lesser
part of his game but it's still going to
be a part of his game i think it has to
be a part of his game and he's getting
protected like that there's going to be
some wide open running lanes i think he
needs a slide be careful but let's not
act like he's never going to run again
because he still has that athleticism he
had pre-injury
right and i love the fact that he's
embracing running because a lot of times
when you come off a major injury like
that you're more likely to protect your
your your leg or your ankle or whatever
and not run right now it's like he's
embracing he's like look i'm back there
nope i can give me 10 or 15 yards he
takes off he doesn't look like you said
as explosive but it's not you don't look
at him and say oh man this guy just came
off a major foot injury as well so he's
he's doing good i'm really proud of that
right i don't think the beginning of
this season could be going any better
for the dallas cowboys any better you
didn't even know if that could be able
to play the arm injury the foot injury
the leader the leg injury what's the
offensive line what the heck's the
defense gonna be it couldn't be going
any better for dallas get to the
patriots your fourth team right here
patriots win in a loss i think that's
well put the patriots win like we were
leaving that building going like man
new england like i know they lost this
game but there's a lot of smiles of
these new england fans walking out of
here where are they right now what's the
state of the union yeah we yeah we
talked about that sunday jack you and i
we looked at the fans and we saw that
they were excited that they were smiling
they were down a little bit but they had
a joyful enthusiasm and we talked about
it and i said look the reason why
they're doing that is because they found
out offensively that they can move the
ball that they have their franchise
quarterback you got to be excited about
that as a coach as a fan as a person
part of that organization defensively
you know that bill belichick he can
still bring it he can still draw up some
of the best defensive game plans out
there and he had tom brady rattled so if
i'm the patriots even though that's a
loss how do you not build a lot of
confidence coming from that game knowing
that you can compete that mac jones can
compete with the goat toe to toe and
even though they lost on the field goal
in in like terrible conditions the
patriots should know they can play with
anybody
and watch this guy i mean you look at
him and pressure direct go ahead go
ahead jack
yeah i was just going to say i mean now
i want to hear your take over some of
these games so i may lay right back out
because now we're now back to talking
mac jones in this offense but look at
him right there kind of stepping up in
the pocket what do you see as he
maneuvers through the pocket what
impresses you most there
just you know what the poise just the
poise because a lot of times you get
this you get a fast middle linebacker
coming at you 250 pounds you want to
panic he just stayed there and at the
last minute he just shifted over and he
kept his vision down the field that's
having instincts that's having a great
feel for the pocket and and this young
dude like drew brees said he hasn't seen
a quarterback that has the poise that
this kid has across the league and if
there's any kid that i'm taking a rookie
quarterback i'm taking mac jones at this
point in time because of how calm and
how cool he is reminds me of brady
yeah he does he does to me too it's
crazy to say that it's so crazy to say
that he felt right he fell right into
their lap it's like such a bill
belichick move or he not he's not that
coach or that organization trading all
the way up giving away draft picks no no
he fell all the way down to him at the
perfect spot to pick him and i want to
set you up for this one too because you
had a conversation with josh mcdaniels
before the game what was the big point
that he hammered home to you what was
the big thing he said because you were
confident mac jones before the game even
started
yeah i just asked him i said man you i
know you liked the rookie quarterback
and he was he just started just a huge
smile on his face like he just smiled a
huge smile and he says rod it's only
been a few games it's only been a few
games and he just kind of just pushed me
and he just took off running and
laughing so you know he's just really
pumped up and excited the kid is smart
he's competitive he has it that's what
josh he's got it rodney he's got it so
everything that it is he has and that's
why we as patriots fans we're excited
about the young man
he does okay my final question on this
game just because i i love learning
defensive football from you
the game plan i mean you laid this thing
out like on tuesday of how the patriots
were going to defend tom brady it played
out in the exact way that you said it
would even down to the trick plays on
offense you're like and watch for trick
plays two big huge trick plays that gave
him sparks in that game but focus me in
on this game plan defensively from
belichick what was he doing how is he
mixing up those defenses and what's the
point of why he mixes up those defenses
well the key is variety you want to
always show tom brady variety everyone
talks about well tom's he's seen
everything yeah he has seen every
coverage but at the same time when he
comes to the line of scrimmage he still
has to figure out what you're doing
so what i suggested is play a lot of
man-to-man early on because you know
with the rain and the weather conditions
top you got to challenge that quick
passing game all that dink and dunk
stuff if you're playing man coverage you
can do that you can force tom brady to
try to fit the ball in those tight
windows but also pressure when you
pressure him it not necessarily blitz
him outside but pressure him directly in
his face with an extra linebacker if you
can't get there with four bring an extra
linebacker make it five you create
one-on-ones across the board somebody
has to win matthew judon had a great
game and then sometimes you don't you
can't play man you don't want to blitz
sometimes you want to give your defense
a break what is that rush three drop
eight keep two safeties deep and now you
force tom brady to hold on to the ball
or you force him to check it down it's a
pretty simple game plan um but it's a
pretty simple game plan that a lot of
people don't understand but i've been
there with coach belichick drawing up
defensive game plans against tennessee
titans the great coach offense with
peyton manning and this man is a he's a
genius if you just like he says do your
job
the defense can compete with anybody
yeah and the point you made that really
resonated with me and i couldn't even
wait to come home tell my dad and i gave
you full credit for the point but it was
you know how they play all that man
early but then they give the dbs breaks
because if you think about it my brother
played defensive back too so i'm always
kind of looking at things from that
angle you as well
it can be exhausting playing all that
man-to-man coverage every single snap
right rod so then when you go you rush
three and you drop eight explain how
you're giving them a little breather
right there and why those dbs may need
it
yeah it's just you know when you when
you're chasing guys around i mean these
guys are fast they're athletic and you
know it's tough you get tired i mean
it's not even it's the first month of
the season you're still trying to get
yourself in shape so as a coach when you
see your guys playing tight man-to-man
coverage imagine if you're jc jackson
and you're covering mike evans a guy
that's 6'5 that runs a 4-3
every single play you need a break you
can't play man-to-man every coverage so
sometimes you blitz sometimes it might
be a man blitz it might be a zone blitz
sometimes you sit back and you play zone
with with eight guys dropping back and
you force the quarterback to hold the
ball and you you protect yourself with
two deep safeties it's just it's just
football one-on-one
it is it is genius though like the way
you describe it it is genius because it
solves two things right it's like from
tom brady's perspective it's like trying
to hit 105 mile an hour fastball and
then come right back and try to hit a 45
mile an hour curveball it's like i i
don't know what they're gonna do i just
like i'm never comfortable back here and
you're giving your dbs a break so that
they're fresh again to play man-to-man
it's like to me it's just beautiful and
it explains sort of the genius of bill
belichick okay let's get you got one
more thing go let me make one let me i'm
gonna make one more point and and this
is a point that marlon humphrey and he's
an all-pro corner and they the baltimore
ravens like to move him around they'll
put him on a tight end they'll put him
on the slot they'll put him you know um
out wide this guy has given up a lot of
touchdowns this year and he's all pro
and it's the first month of the season
and that's what happens when you're
playing a lot of man a lot of blitz you
move the guy around he gets tired i
don't care if you're marlon humphrey you
want to top two or three cornerbacks in
the league and he's gotten beat by a
fourth receiver he's gotten beat by a
second receiver he's gotten beat for
some big time touchdowns this year so it
just shows you that dbs can get tired
and and this is a prime example of all
pro getting tired
i love it let's get to your final
takeaway the cardinals only undefeated
team remaining why can't they be beat
there in arizona
[ __ ] kyla murray has just absolutely
been outstanding and um you look at aj
green and all the wide receivers and
what they're doing they're just playing
great complimentary football the defense
is flying around buddha baker isaiah
simmons
chandler jones they just right now they
just have a full arsenal on both offense
and defense but the thing i like is
about colin murray is he's really taking
control it seems like he's matured he's
talking to his teammates he's
communicating he's not going to the
sideline pouting or doing anything like
that i just love his patience and his
maturity and the guy the kid is so smart
when he's running around he doesn't take
any big hits
i just think he's doing a fabulous job
of leading and his team no matter how
good of a player is if he's a crummy
leader they won't follow him but he's
doing a great job of leading and man
props to him right now i think he's got
the lead as far as the league mvp
this team's dangerous this team's really
really dangerous like kyle murray is is
freakishly athletic back there and we've
made the point before that i mean dbs
can't run with this guy you can forget
about defensive end sometimes they don't
even know he's out of there by the time
he's across the goal line i mean he's
freaky freaked but then you add on the
fact that you got aj green who was a top
tier wide receiver when healthy i mean
he was cincinnati he was an awesome wide
receiver with no real quarterback his
entire career
pairing up with deandre hopkins and
christian kirk
that is some weapons on the outside that
you're working with there and then the
defensive pieces that they put together
i think isaiah simmons is finding a much
better role a role that is something
he's used to flying around being
involved in all these plays that first
year it felt like they didn't know
exactly how to use simmons which was
somewhat surprising to me i think they
found out that perfect role for him now
and he's all over the place what are you
seeing from simmons in particular
just because don't move him around he's
a he's a young player and you can't move
everyone around like micah parsons they
found one spot for him they said we're
going to teach you the spot and he's
learning this spot and he's comfortable
with the spot so now he knows his drops
he knows his run fits and he knows his
call so he's a lot more comfortable
because he's getting a lot more
consistency from where the spot that
he's playing
but
one other thing i want to do
you mentioned eight go ahead
you mentioned one thing about aj green
and the thing that stands out to me is
he was a fabulous player before all the
injuries happened but for him to have
the humility to come to arizona and put
his ego down and say you know what i'm
willing to be a second receiver a third
receiver whatever it takes in order for
in order for us to win
that just that speaks volume to the type
of player he is to the type of person
that he is because a lot of guys that
had made the type of money that he's
made and had the type of success that
he's at
they can't they can't
they can't put their ego down like that
so a lot of props to aj green man
it's so well put and you know what's
wound up happening because of him
putting his ego aside is that he's he's
kind of become the number one wide
receiver and like i understand that is
deandre hopkins but take a look at their
targets hopkins this year 25 targets aj
green 24. who has more yards aj green
248 hopkins at 225 who has more
touchdowns deandre has one more
touchdown than aj who has two hopkins
has three that's great so it's really
like it's it's a debate at this point
and it's because he's been willing to be
that guy who's team first and it's just
the perfect role for him the perfect
place for him at the perfect point in
his career he was ready to get out of
cincinnati even though you know all
these new young weapons are here with
burro i think it was just time for a
little change almost like with tom brady
get down to tampa get to some nice
weather there in arizona and some good
things are starting to happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports